[THEME MUSIC]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY: Welcome to
Google I/O's Main Street.
I'm Timothy.
FLORINA: I'm Florina.
TODD: I'm still Todd.
TIMOTHY: And we're going
to go have some fun.
TODD: Fun!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD: How's your I/O been?
SPEAKER 1: Amazing.
TODD: What's been your favorite
thing you've seen so far?
SPEAKER 1: I think
the discussion
on Artificial Intelligence
and creativity.
SPEAKER 2: TensorFlow.js.
TensorFlow.js and Node.js,
which has been launched today.
Awesome stuff.
TIMOTHY: You're a JavaScript
programmer, I take it?
SPEAKER 2: Yes, that's correct.
I actually run and
organize a meetup
in Bucharest, Bucharest JS.
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
That's cool.
SPEAKER 2: So that's
super exciting for us.
TIMOTHY: What about you?
SPEAKER 3: Oh, I think
the future of AI session
this morning was
very interesting.
TODD: What's been your
favorite session so far?
SPEAKER 4: The
session on ML kit.
I'm over the moon excited about
this for our product, which
is called the Native Script.
So, building mobile
apps with JavaScript
and using ML on the device?
Unbelievable.
SPEAKER 5: I think
the one that I just
saw with [INAUDIBLE]
starter kit on polymer.
It was given by Monica.
So, it was pretty cool.
She had like a game
in the presentation,
and you had to go up a level,
and really cool graphics.
SPEAKER 6: So I have been
following John [INAUDIBLE]
for like the longest time ever.
And I had no idea--
I mean, kind of creepily--
and I had no idea
that he was going to be here.
And I saw on the
schedule that he was here
and I immediately went.
And he talked about
designing towards inclusion,
and how important
bringing technology
to the remote sectors and
having remote workers is.
And It was extremely
exciting, and I
was very happy to see him here.
So that was fantastic.
TIMOTHY: That's why,
in Batman v. Superman,
Batman is always going to win.
Because brains
always beats brawn.
TODD: Is that true?
TIMOTHY: I think so.
SPEAKER 1: What's
you favorite thing?
TIMOTHY: My favorite thing?
This right here.
SPEAKER 1: Why?
TIMOTHY: Because I think my
favorite thing about Google I/O
is when people from
around the world
gather in a single place
with shared interests,
and get to talk
about the future.
SPEAKER 5: There's a lot
of focus on diversity.
I mean, even the speakers,
and the audience.
Like it's a really
diverse audience.
It's great.
I think I never saw an audience
so diverse at the conference.
So it's pretty awesome.
SPEAKER 1: And I
think we all agree
that it looks like a
festival with programmers.
SPEAKER 2: Not necessarily a
conference, but a festival,
right?
TIMOTHY: What was your
favorite non-session thing?
SPEAKER 1: The arcade night.
SPEAKER 2: The
arcade, definitely
the arcade last night.
TIMOTHY: Did you see the pinball
machine made out of balloons?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, it was amazing.
TIMOTHY: It was like
a balloon animal dude,
and he made a pinball machine.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah,
that seems difficult.
TIMOTHY: So what is your
favorite non-session thing
about I/O this year?
SPEAKER 7: You know, it's
just hanging out with people
that we like, sitting on
the lawn and just chatting.
It's the best.
SPEAKER 8: So we have a
huge community of GDEs,
and we had a really
unique opportunity
to see kind of a bunch
of them in one place,
so it's really awesome.
SPEAKER 1: The experiment
music was pretty awesome.
Crazy.
TIMOTHY: The future music?
SPEAKER 1: Yes,
the one right here.
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
That's where I was.
SPEAKER 5: But our favorite
thing was the bouncy world.
You know, the Android
suits fighting.
It was hilarious.
TIMOTHY: It's like
those sumo suits.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY: So you all going
to come back next year?
SPEAKER 3: Yeah,
hopefully, definitely.
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
Well, we'll see you then.
Thank you so much.
Well, here we are at
the end of Main Street.
I hope you've had as
much fun as we have.
I'm Timothy, and I'm here
with my new BFFs, Todd--
TODD: Um, I'm pretty sure
it's pronounced, bffffff.
TIMOTHY: Now I know that.
And Florina.
FLORINA: Hi, bestie.
TIMOTHY: Remember to
check out all the videos
at g.co/io/guide, and we'll
see you at Google I/O 2019.
TODD: Bye, we'll miss you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]